a greatest thing we can do is get rid of
the virus because then everything comes
back together then ever you don't need
stimulus once that's happening now what
is happening is the sympathy stim you
know we're talking about three trillion
not just two trillion three trillion it
could even go to six and we're gonna
have a tremendous year next year because
of what we're doing and laying the seeds
that was the president last night at the
town hall the Fox News town hall they
were in front of the Lincoln Memorial it
was a beautiful sight we all watched it
last night
let's bring in House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy to react to that
statement good morning to you
congressman good morning thanks for
having me back up good morning you're
welcome so do you think there should be
more relief yes I do I mean the one
thing I see and I'm back in Washington
today I'm watching the Senate work I
think the house needs to work I'm on a
bipartisan panel Republicans laid out
today a plan a four-phase plan how
Congress can work I mean we sit here and
we look at the doctors to delivery
drivers to dispatchers they're doing
everything they can to work through this
pandemic except Congress is not
Republicans have a plan to get us back
to work and the first phase is let's get
our committees back we don't have to
have all of our committees at once but
let's work on the bills that are most
needed
that's about funding that's about
national defense that's about our water
resources they can take up the big room
so they have the social distancing these
bills are more not partisan but
bipartisan bicameral so they're not
wasting anybody's time they're needed
essential bills once we pass those you
could bring all of Congress back to vote
and we change our voting structure that
it's a longer vote not everybody's on
the floor at once we could put
plexiglass up much like our grocery
stores do in the areas that are
congested these are the ways that we can
make Congress actually work because I
believe were essential instead of
staying home yeah what did you make over
the weekend mr. leader of Mitch
McConnell and Nancy Pelosi put out a
letter together and said that while the
president had offered some of the quick
testing machinery for Congress they
declined it saying it should go to other
would that kind of wouldn't I mean they
used it at the White House so that
everybody who comes in contact with the
top executives of the country they know
whether or not that person has it do you
think micchon and Nancy got it right
Congress doesn't need that stuff
no I I actually have a difference of
opinion I would have it here remember as
we open up you have to be prepared for
any flare-up and that's how you deal
with it and having a machine here
especially when Congress is working when
you have the individuals to staff you
want to limit the number of staff the
press and others in those side those
committee rooms you can test that's
probably just a hundred more tests in
that process maybe it would keep us
safer it would keep the essential work
of Congress going instead of staying
home I think that would be critical at
the same time and if there is a flare-up
you make sure that there it does not
continue to grow you quarantine the area
and you have tracing to be able to
protect well know that about it you have
a plan to get back to work the Senate
wants to give back is back to work Nancy
Pelosi ran for the hills so hopefully
people understand there's a reason to be
fearful but there's a way to do it the
same way you can go to CBS you can go to
useful food store there's ways to do it
in other stores and there's ways to do
it in Congress you are an essential
worker let's talk about California
what's also essential is that the
governor looks at your state as diverse
as it actually is so many of getting
upset because they're being lumped in
with Los Angeles and they are defying
the lockdown orders I don't hope I say
this right MODOK Sutter and in yuba they
are stewing their own thing and opened
up stores and defying the governor who's
gonna win this standoff well I hope
there is not a standoff remember
California is 40 million people 12% of
the entire population of the United
States lives in California but
California is about four states in
themselves and there's areas that have
dense population and some that have
large social distancing those counties
that you mentioned are not very large
but large in size but not in population
just as the governors are making
decisions and not the president about
their states we should allow local
government to make decisions because
they
best so they know how to manage and deal
with that situation that's why one size
does not fit all for California less
work with the local community just to
watch this governor make a decision
about the beaches in Orange County
while the locals wanted to be able to
open it up they had social distancing
it's warm outside and others and they're
the ones with the local public health
that are dealing with these situations
they are best of knowledge on the ground
let's coordinate together and let's not
make one-size-fits-all just as we
wouldn't for the entire nation now
remember in California we have a
Democrat Speaker of the House that
Democrat speaker in the State Assembly
is actually bringing their members back
this week unfortunately in Congress
which I believe is more essential is not
but we have a plan to bring people back
in a safe manner working with public
health and others just as I was in Home
Depot and Lowe's this weekend I think
Congress can open up put some plexiglass
and actually get to work thank you so
much leader for being with us